Ich bin der Diensthabende aus der Situation und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Patientengespräch durchführen.
Wenn Sie damit ein Verstanden sehen, sind Sie?
Ja, ja, klar.
Danke schön. Kurzum aber auf den Bergen jetzt ein paar andere Fragen stellen.
Dann können wir so in den aktuellen Beschwören übergehen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verständlich vor der Frage haben, dann haben Sie sich dabei.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Nicole Meyer.
Nicole mit am Ende L.E., Maya mit auf Umlaut C.
Und in der Mitte C.
Und Maya mit umlaut A.I.
Okay.
Frau Maya, wie heißen Sie Frau Maya und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin noch 57 Jahre alt.
Ich bin geboren am 5.07.65.
65.
Das freut mich. Danke.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie so seit und wie groß sind Sie, Frau Maya?
Ich bin 1.63 und ich wiege 71 Kilo.
71 Kilo. Okay, ich verstehe.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Was führt Sie zu uns, Frau Maya?
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also ich habe so heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Und zwar, ja, das hat eigentlich schon von der Weile angefangen.
Aber jetzt ist mir so sehr schlecht.
Und gestern habe ich dann, war ich sehr erschrocken, da habe ich gesehen,
dass ich so blutigen Stuhl hatte.
Und auch dann später am Abend hatte ich so ganz dunklen Stuhl.
Auch heute Morgen, da habe ich gedacht, also das ist mir jetzt doch ein bisschen unheimlich.
Aber gehe ich doch mal eben schnell hier in die Klinik.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sie haben sehr gut gemacht hier, um in der Klinik zu kommen.
Das könnte erst ein Notwendig sein.
Und ja, seit gestern Abend, Sie haben gesagt, eine Schmerzen haben.
Nein, die Schmerzen habe ich schon seit Wochen, wissen Sie?
Seit Wochen ist aber ein bisschen klein.
Und aber seit gestern immer diese Schmerzen schlimmer geworden, richtig?
Ja, sie sind schon länger eigentlich immer schlimmer geworden.
Aber gestern ging es dann gar nicht mehr.
Und jetzt sind die wirklich heftig.
Und die Schmerzen sind so im Oberbauch.
Und mir ist jetzt so schlecht.
Könnte Sie sagen, wo die Schmerzen am stärksten sind?
Im ganzen Mitte Oberbauch, rechter Seite oder linke Seite?
Also ich würde sagen, in der Mitte vom Oberbauch.
Okay, okay.
Und zwar sind die Schmerzen eigentlich besonders immer nach dem Essen.
Oh, macht das erst so.
Ja, ich weiß.
Okay, ja, haben Sie...
Jetzt mag ich schon gar nichts mehr essen.
Wenn man sofort weiß, das tut sofort weh hinterher.
Denn das ist immer nur so ein kleines Häppchenmal.
Aber ja, ich habe jetzt also gar keinen Appetit.
Ich kann es verstehen.
Und haben Sie Buschschmerzen oder enge Gefühle?
Oder haben Sie das Gefühl, als ob jemand auf Ihrer Busch sitzen würde?
Nein, sowas habe ich nicht. Nein, nein.
Nein, das sind richtig heftige, heftige starke Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Husten bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay.
Es würde gerne ich über dieses Schmerzen etwas fragen.
Wie stark die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkeler von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leicht, 10 sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht.
Es könnte sein 8 oder 9.
Ja, also es hat natürlich langsam angefangen.
Aber jetzt sind die Schmerzen zum Teil wirklich so stark.
Würde ich schon sagen, bis zu 8.
8, okay.
Das ist ein starker Schmerzen.
Aber ich darf nicht Ihnen einen Schmerzmittel geben.
Zusätzlich ist es sehr wichtig,
bevor ich Ihre körperliche Untersuchung mache.
Nach der Untersuchung werde ich Sie einen Schmerzmittel anbieten.
Okay? Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Und ich trage die Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion aus,
zum Beispiel in der Unten.
Ich bin hier oben auf den oberen Bauchteil so konzentriert.
Ich verstehe.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen etwas genauer beschreiben?
Sieht nicht mehr so, dass sie dumpfdruckend sind?
Ja, es drückt ganz stark.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Übelkeit, Frau Maier?
Ja, sagte ich ja, das ist mir ganz schlecht.
Ich muss mich zwar nicht übergeben, aber mir ist unheimlich schlecht.
Aber mussten Sie sich nicht übergeben?
Nein.
Ja, jetzt können wir zu unserem aktuellen Thema gehen.
Sie haben gesagt, in Ihrem Stuhl haben Sie Blut bemerkt.
Aber im Laufe der Zeit, diese Blut etwas dunkler geworden.
Nein, das Blut, also einmal habe ich Blut richtig gesehen.
Und dann gestern Abend spät und auch heute Morgen
war der Stuhlgang eben so ganz dunkel.
Ganz dunkel, wie ein Tär, können wir sagen?
Ja, so ganz schwarz-schwarz-dunkler.
Herr Verstehsü, haben Sie Probleme mit dem Wasser lassen?
Haben Sie solche Beschwerden?
Ich habe mich da keine beschwerten, nein.
Herr Verstehsü, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, dass die Schmerzen verbinden mit vielen Seiten mit dem Essen.
Haben Sie etwas Sonderes bemerkt, ein scharfes Essen oder Gewürziges?
Eigentlich ist das fast nach allem Essen.
Nach allem Essen.
Haben Sie Fieber gemessen oder mussten Sie sich...
Hab ich nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich fieberig eigentlich nicht.
Schlafen Sie gut oder haben Sie Probleme beim Ein- oder Durchschlafen?
Normalerweise kann ich ganz gut schlafen.
Aber jetzt heute Nacht, weil mir so schlecht war und ich Bauchschmerzen hatte,
habe ich natürlich nicht gut geschlafen.
Ich verstehe Sie ganz gut.
Okay, haben Sie Nachtschweiß bemerkt?
Oder in der letzten Zeit haben Sie an Gewicht verloren?
Ja, Gewicht habe ich tatsächlich abgenommen.
War ich ja nicht unglücklich darüber, nicht?
Ich habe zwei Kilo abgenommen in den letzten zwei Wochen.
In den zwei Wochen, zwei Kilogramm, ja, ich verstehe.
Aber nächtliche Schwitzen haben Sie keine.
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Was ich vorhin habe, dass ich manchmal so so brennen habe,
dass ich dann nachts aufstoßen muss und das ist so ein bisschen unangenehm.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
Das war mein Thema.
Ich werde Sie diese Fragen stellen.
Brauchen Sie mehrere Kisten zum Schlafen wegen dieses Dortbrennen,
bei der Nacht zum Beispiel?
Na, bisher bin ich mit einem dicken Kissen ausgekommen.
Okay.
Ja, jetzt möchte ich gerne ein kleines Zusammenfassung machen, Frau Meier.
Sie haben seit vielen Wochen eine komische Gefühle und Schmerzen
in Ihrem Oberbau, aber seit gestern Abend haben Sie sehr starke Schmerzen.
Sie mussten drei oder mehrmals Ihre Stuhl, eine blutig,
oder ja, Sie haben eine blutige Stuhl bemerkt
und im Laufe der Zeit diese Stuhl immer dunkler geworden ist,
ist es ganz schwarz.
Sie haben Übelkeit, aber mussten Sie sich nicht übergeben.
Ich glaube, das war alles. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie mich...
Ich glaube, das sind schon die wichtigsten Sachen.
Jetzt würde ich gerne nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte fragen, Frau Meier.
Leiden Sie an chronische Alkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel
die Blutzuckerkrankheit oder Magengeschwör?
Was ich habe, was natürlich alle haben in meinem Alter,
ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck
und das Cholesterin ist auch ein bisschen erhöht.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Blutdruckdruckdruck...
Ja, das ist jetzt neun Jahre her, dass man das festgestellt hat.
Sehen Sie regelmäßig, messen Sie...
Ja, ich gehe da schon zum Arzt.
Ja, sehr gut, Sie haben das gut gemacht.
Nehmen Sie, da liegen eine bestimmte Medikamente.
Ich meine dagegen diese...
Ja, ich nehme da etwas ein, aber Augenblick,
wie das heißt, das fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Ich weiß, das eine wegen des Cholesterins, das heißt ein Statin.
Ach ja, Statin ist der Ja.
Und das andere ist irgendwas, was dem Blutdruck senkt,
aber ich komme jetzt nicht auf den Namen.
Ich nehme mal, haben Sie mir die Medikamentinistin dabei?
Nein, die habe ich natürlich jetzt in der Eile zu Hause liegen lassen.
Könnten Sie mir Ihren Hausarzt, Namen von Hausarzt verraten?
Ja, das ist Dr. Möller.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, ich werde mit Dr. Möller diese Kontakt nehmen.
Und außer dieses zwei Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig
oder gelegentlich eine andere Medikamente zum Schlafen, oder?
Ja, also ich habe noch eine Sache, die mich eigentlich schon fast mein Leben lang begleitet.
Ich habe eine Schuppenflechte.
Und da musste ich manchmal Cortisonseile behalten nutzen.
Diese Attacke sind nicht so häufig bei der Schuppenflechte?
Nein, das ist nicht so oft, aber ich musste halt ein bisschen gucken danach.
Diese Medikamente wie ein Creme?
Genau, das ist eine Cortisoncreme.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Ja, Frau Naja, sind bei Ihnen allergienbekannt?
Eigentlich nur braunes Pflaster, was anderes wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Na ja, da gibt es so kleine Pickelchen und das Juckt und ja...
Ich verstehe.
Und jetzt würde ich gerne nach Ihrer Lebensgewohnheit und fragen,
Frau Naja, brauchen Sie?
Ja, also, ja, ich rauche schon.
Also, kein ganzes Päckchen am Tag, aber 15 Degaretten am Tag, Frau Riech-Wulf.
Ja, aber sehr viel.
Seit wann rauchen Sie, Frau Naja?
Ich habe erst mit 30 so etwas angefangen, also noch nicht so lange.
Es gibt ungefähr 20 Jahre oder sieben oder zwanzig Jahre.
Ja, ja, so etwas in dem Tag.
Es ist zu viel, Frau Naja, ich empfehle Ihnen ein bisschen retuzieren.
Ich empfehle Ihnen auch hier in unserem Stationklinikum,
gibt es eine Beratungsstelle für die Ämter.
Jetzt will ich mich erst mal um meinen Bauch kümmern.
Ja, okay, okay, wir werden diese Stoffe nach dem Gespräch in Buch sprechen.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also, ich trinke abends mein Bier zum Abendbrot.
Ja, im Sommer mehr als jetzt im Winter abends trinke ich mal,
im Winter trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein, aber ja, nicht viel.
Ja, ich verstehe das gut.
Ja, jetzt würde ich gerne nach Ihrer Familiengeschichte fragen,
Leben ihr Eltern noch, Frau Meyer?
Mein Vater ist verstorben, aber meine Mutter liegt noch.
Ja, es tut mir leid, wo angestorbt ist er gestorben.
Er hatte einen Verkehrsunfall, er hatte einen Verkehrsunfall
und ist an den Folgen dann verstorben.
Okay, wann war das?
Ich war schon lange her.
Okay, ich verstehe Sie, das war sehr schlecht aufzuhalten.
Er ist schon fein.
Und bei Ihrer Mutter?
Ja, eigentlich war die immer ganz gut beieinander,
aber jetzt hat sie ein offenes Bein.
Eigentlich ist sie auch schon sehr alt, aber da sagt man,
sie hat vielleicht so eine Verschlusskrankheit im Bein.
Ja, das weiß ich, das ist eine Atrielle.
Wie gesagt, Hauptauschlager, Hauptschlagader, Probleme,
weil deswegen, okay, sind Sie gut behandelt,
bei der Medikamenteur?
Ja, Sie wird jetzt behandelt und hoffen,
dass es wieder besser wird, dass die Wohnen wieder zugehen.
Ja, ich hoffe so.
Wenn Sie Probleme haben, können Sie zum Vorhör in unserer Kolonialikum
mit Ihrer Mutter zu kommen.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Frau Meyer?
Ich bin Buchhändlerin.
Buchhändlerin?
Händler, ja, ja, ich meinte, das ist Buchhändler.
Das ist eine mit dieser Recherchierung und Steuerberater.
Nee, nee, das ist Buchhaltung.
Ich bin Buchhändlerin, nicht verkaufe Bücher.
Ja, ich bin ein ausländischer Arzt,
Deutsch ist ein bisschen schwer für mich,
aber jetzt ich verstehe.
Okay, haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Nein, eigentlich zurzeit nicht.
Wir hatten ein bisschen Stress zur Corona-Zeit,
aber jetzt geht es uns ja gut.
Ich verstehe, ganz gut.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Aber Sie Kinder?
Ja, das sind Stiefkinder, also die hat man mit in die Ehe gebracht.
Ich verstehe, ja.
Das bedeutet, dass Sie Ihre zweiten verheiraten, oder?
Nein, seine zweite Ehe.
Ich verstehe jetzt Ihre Ehe,
meine zweiten verheiraten.
Ja, Frau Maia, ich habe alle meine Fragen gestellt
und ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Jetzt würde ich Sie gerne über meine weitere Procedere berichten.
Ich werde Sie in der Sterline köpelische untersuchen.
Ich meine Ihre Bauabtasten
und auch Ihre eine digitale Rektal-Untersuchung durchführen müssen.
Ich habe eine.
Dann nehme ich Ihnen Blut ab
und dann einen Stuhlprobe von Ihnen bekommen
und auch eine Sonnografie abdäumen durchführen.
Was ist eine Sonnografie abdäumen?
Ja, Bauch-Ultra-Schall, ich meine.
Die machen ein Ultraschall vom Bauch.
Ja, Ultra-Schall vom Bauch.
Ich möchte, ja, das mache ich ein Fehler.
Wenn Sie mit allen Befunden vorlegen,
können wir zu Ihrer Situation widersprechen.
Haben Sie Fragen an mich oder möchten Sie etwas hinzuführen?
Ich glaube, ich kann mir das jetzt erst mal hierbleiben.
Ja, mindestens zwei oder drei Stunden müssen Sie hierbleiben.
Als Erstes werde ich Sie von Ihnen ein Vitalparameter,
zum Beispiel Bluthochdruh und Herzritmus bestimmen.
Dann ist es eine notwendige Situation.
Sie müssen hier bei uns mindestens drei Stunden bleiben.
Okay, dann weiß ich Bescheid.
Dankeschön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Ich habe ein paar.
Oh ja, jetzt geht es los.
Sie haben so die Flüssigke gesprochen.
Vielleicht habe ich ganz alles nicht verfolgen.
Haben Sie, wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Hat er nicht gefragt.
Das ist mein fehlende Thema.
Sie hatte vor sechs Jahren,
hat Sie eine Hanleiterschiene bekommen wegen Nierstein?
Vor sechs Jahren?
Also Intervention.
Können Sie wieder sagen, Hanleiter?
Schiene.
Eine Hanleiterschiene.
Wegen diese Steine, oder?
Ja.
Aber Dr. Alici hat noch eine Frage.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft,
ich meine Ihre Kindheit und gegen Corona?
Ja, stimmt, hatte auch nicht gefragt.
Gegen Corona bin ich natürlich geimpft.
Ja, ich habe Kontakt bei der Arbeit.
Und in der Kindheit, also ich nehme an,
dass ich da gut abgedeckt bin.
Noch was?
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht.
Das war es.
Noch eine fehlt.
Hätten Sie hinterlässt, das seid eine Reise gemacht?
Keine Reise.
Ich habe mich zumindest nicht bekannt.
Die Operation ist komplikationslos verlassen?
Ja.
Ich bin.
Sind Sie mehr dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Beispiel Wellen in Formik oder?
Also Sie sind besonders stark nach dem Essen
und dann reduzieren Sie sich wieder ein bisschen.
Es gibt also so ein bisschen Wellenbewegungen.
Entweder beschwerden Sie.
Ob ich ähnliche Beschwerden früher schon gehabt habe?
Ja, früher schon.
Nein, eigentlich ja nicht.
Haben Sie gegen Schuppenflicken eine Medikamente eingenommen?
Nein, eingenommen nicht, da habe ich nur äußerlich
eine Cortisonseite.
Seit einer Woche dagegen nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Ach so gegen die Bauchschmerzen habe ich nichts eingenommen.
Nein.
Haben Sie oft Herzrasen stolpen?
Nein, mein Herz glaube ich ist total in Ordnung.
Keine Probleme.
Danke schön, das ist das.
Lindelung, haben Sie sich erinnern, dass die Schmerzen,
Windelung...
Ach so, können Sie sich erinnern, ob irgendetwas Schmerzen
gelindert hat, mal sehen.
Ja.
Ist mir jetzt nicht so richtig, auch, wie die Schmerzen waren
eigentlich die ganze Zeit, die jetzt immer wurden immer
weniger und ja, Lindelung wüsste ich jetzt nicht,
was da, was geholfen hätte.
Können wir erst das hier anfangen?
Ja, natürlich.
Okay.
Schönen guten Abend Frau Oberärztin.
Ich habe gerade eine neue Patientin gesehen
und möchte Ihnen vorstellen, haben Sie seit für mich?
Ja, wie haben Sie denn gesehen?
Vielen Dank.
Diese heißt Nicole S. Meier.
Sie ist 57 Jahre alt und ist am 5. Juli 1965 geboren.
Sie ist seit 1,63 m groß und 71 kg schwer.
Frau Meier...
Ja, total, sie wird ja nicht mehr wachsen, ne?
Also sie ist 1,63 m groß und wiegt zurzeit 71 kg.
Ja, das ist...
zurzeit ist für, ja, ich...
Ja, okay, alles klar.
Ja, mein Kopf ist einem SIM-Platz.
Und Frau Meier stellte sich heute bei uns
wegen seit gestern Abend erst der
progredierende Drucken der Schmerzen im Oberbrauch vor.
Sie gaben seit gestern, Sie gaben,
dass Sie seit gestern 3 Mal Melana, Melena gehabt haben
und aus der Demonstration fügte sie hin so,
dass sie in der Patience und auch Nausea haben.
Sie erwähnte, ja, die Schmerzen würden auf einer
Schmerzkader bei 8 mit ohne Ausstrahlung liegen
und Sie gaben, dass die Schmerzen nach dem Essen
immer mehr verschlimmern würden.
Und, ja, Fragen nach Angina pectoris duspne
und Probleme bei der Wasselmektion wurden von den Patienten vereint.
Und Sie klagte über viele Seiten so Pyrosis
und auch Ruktus, sauberes Ausstoß und Sortbränen.
Und, ja, ich würde für alle aktuelle Schmerzen
diese sagen.
Und, ja, Sie haben auch gesagt, dass Sie innerhalb
2 Wochen von ca. 2 kg am Gewicht verloren
und, ja, die anderen regertetiv an einem Mesis und
unaufwählig.
Die Leide an Vorerkrankungen, leide sie seit 9 Jahren
Artilleripatonie, aber hypercholesterin,
Nemi, ja, die haben Reis.
Und gegen diese 2 Vorerkrankungen
nehme sie Symmastatin, ich glaube 20 mg,
ich habe keinen, ja, diese nicht gefragt haben.
Und auch wegen Pysoriasis Cortisol, Salve,
ob und bei, wer darf und auch so.
Außer diese 2 Medikamente nehme sie
eine andere Medikamente und
hat sie nicht auch hohen Blutdruck?
Hohen Blutdruck, ja, Sie haben gesagt, aber
Ihre Medikamente ist nicht dabei, so ich plane,
um Ihren Haushaus zu sprechen und von Ihnen
eine Information bekommen, ich glaube so.
Zubekommen, ja.
Und bei der Patientin wurde vor 6 Jahren
wegen einer Handleiter-Steine
eine Handleiter-Schiene-Operation durchgepült.
Ich weiß das nicht.
Und sie sei allergic auf Brauenfläster
und sie bekommen Puritus und Vesical-Tagegen.
Sie tabakkonsum beträgt ungefähr
circa 20 Pakumzias.
Sie brauchen 15 Zigaretten pro Tag seit 27 Jahren.
Sie trinken ein Flasche Bier pro Tag
und ab unserer Woche ein glattes Wein.
Und bei der Familie an dem Nese gab es sich Folgen des.
Warte vor vielen Jahren bei einer Verkehrsunfallverstorben
und Mutter hat ein offenes Bein,
aber ja, offenes Bein, ich würde sagen,
ich habe nicht erinnert diese Fabbegriff.
Und...
Purcus, Purcus.
Purcus, ja, Sie haben nicht.
Und Sie sei Buchhandlerin,
Sie habe keine Stress bei der Arbeit,
Sie sei verheiratet und habe 2 Kinder.
Ein Kind, bitte, ein Sohn.
Und ja, das war alles bei der Patente.
Und an amnestische Angaben deuten am 1.
auf ein unteren Gastrointestinal Benutung hin.
Als die Franziak.
Sie haben keine Emesis gehabt.
Deswegen aber diese Melena,
besüglich der oberen Gastrointestinal Benutung,
weil es könnte ein...
Hematohesia, wenn es hinterheran gibt,
Hematohesia sein, sie haben recht oberen Gastrointestinal Benutung.
Ja, als die Franziak.
Was könnte alternativ noch sein?
Alternativ könnte sein ein Dibertikulitis
und auch unteren Gastrointestinal Benutung
und auch politisch Ursula.
Ja, oder ganz schlecht?
Ganz, ganz schlecht.
Das ist Gastrointestinal Benutung.
Oder Ulcus du...
Ja, Sie hat, ich glaube, viele Jahre Ulcus du Vadini,
weil die Schmerzen immer mehr nach dem Essen verstecken.
Ja, aber jetzt gibt es ein Perforation,
dagegen vielleicht, Perforation, oder?
Okay, ich hatte jetzt noch ein Differentialdiagnose.
Die Mann, die lege, hat gesagt, es könnte
ein bösartiger Krankheiten wie Kolonkasinoma,
aber ich denke, dass nicht,
weil gibt es keine familiäre Belastung bei der Patientin
und auch keine B-Symptomatik.
Hast keine, ne?
Sie hat zwar keinen Nachtschweiß, aber sie hat Gewicht verloren.
Aber im Magenkatinom kann man eben nicht ausschließen, ne?
Ja, Sie haben...
Das könnte auch noch was sein.
Was machen Sie denn mit der Patientin jetzt?
Ja, erst einmal ein körperlicher Untersuchung,
besonders digitale, regtale Untersuchung.
Und worauf achten Sie denn besonders, oder was?
Besonders, ich achte auch Stuhlkontinenz und Stuhlfarbe
bei der digitalen, regtale Untersuchung.
Und auch bei der Inspektion gibt es Patientin Blas,
oder es könnte ein Anämie sein,
wegen dieser Blutung vielleicht.
Ja, okay.
Und wo richten Sie denn Ihr Augenmerk besonders hin?
Wo hat Sie Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, die Schmerzen ist im Oberbau,
und jetzt werde ich einen Ecke geschrieben lassen, am 1.
Sie wollen als Erstes Sie doch körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, körperliche Untersuchungen.
Aber achte ich auf diese Inspektion bei der Oberbau,
gibt es hier...
Ja, aber Sie gucken ja nicht nur, sondern was machen Sie noch?
Abtasten, Ab heel scenen.
Und was machst Sie denn?
Hier gibt es hier ja ja, Loslastmärz, Abwehrspinung oder etwas brett, brett harte, brett harte
wegen dieser Perforation.
Ja, okay, gut.
Ja.
Was machen Sie weiter, Diagnostisch?
Ja, Laboruntersuchung ist mein weiter Schritt, wie Blutbild, großes Blutbild und Entzündungsparameter,
Nierenparameter und Gerinnerungsauffarameter.
Hier gibt es auch einen Oberbauchschmerzen. Wir müssen Miokart-Impact ausschließen.
Deswegen brauchen wir Herzinsüme wie Tropolin, die im Einbe.
Dann können wir auch die Dimere machen.
Da sind unsere Laborparameter und auch Stuhldiognostik sehr wichtig.
Hier gibt es auch Geheten, hier in Stuhl gibt es oder nicht.
Ich werde mit der operativen Untersuchung.
Was machen Sie als erstes?
Als erstes ist es leicht.
Ich werde eine abdomen-Sonografie durchfahren.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Hier gibt es eine Perfusion oder andere Möglichkeiten.
Mein Sonografie ist nun nur für Ausfluss.
Ich denke, das ist eine Perforation oder andere Blutung.
Dann werde ich einen Röntgenbauch durchführen.
Hier gibt es Eleus oder andere Perforationen.
Dann machen wir eine ÖGD.
Ja, genau.
Damit wir die Untersuchung mit Hilfe der Methode sehen und beurteilen können.
Geschuhe oder Blutung.
Genau.
Über die Abdomen-Sonografie habe ich hier ausgeliehen können.
Das ist etwas Anagalle oder etwas am Pankreas.
Ja, das ist ein Pankreas und Leberproblem.
Dann gibt es noch einen bestimmten Test, nach dem wir auch machen sollten.
Bei der Stuhl?
Nein, das ist kein Stuhltest.
Ich bin mir aber nicht ganz sicher.
Eine Uriase-Schnelltest.
Wie machen wir das?
Ich habe diese gehört, aber ich bin nicht klar von diesem Bereich.
Ich weiß, dass es eine Uriase-Schnelltest gibt zum HP-Nachweis.
Ja, das können wir.
Oder per Haarmeter, oder ich glaube, es ist nicht so sein.
Das ist hier noch als Hinweis für den Magen, ob da eine Besiedlung ist.
Danke schön.
Wir machen diese Uriase-Test für Magen.
Als therapeutische Massnahme können wir so schnell wie möglich ein Magen schützen,
wie Proton-PPI fangen.
Erst einmal müssen wir diese hammoglibe Werte bestimmen.
Wenn es hier eine tiefe Anämie gibt, dann können wir eine Bluttransfusion planen.
Vielleicht, wenn es möglich ist.
Aber die Patente ist wach und wie gelangst.
Ich glaube, es braucht keine Bluttransfusion.
Wenn es hier Geschwür und Blutung sind,
können wir mit dieser ÖGD ein Behandlungstherapie durchführen.
Während man schaut, kann man auch behandeln.
Ja, wenn man schaut, kann man behandeln.
Als Dauermedikation können wir nach dieser Eingriff 6-monatige
PPI-Therapie durchführen.
Wir empfehlen die Patenten, die vermeiden auf Kaffee,
Schwarzessen, Alkohol, Nikotin.
Genau.
Wir haben auch eine Verbrauchung.
Dann gucken Sie mal, was Sie rausfinden bei der guten Frau Meyer.
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufen, den Sie rauskamen?
Ja.
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Halten Sie mich über die Ergebnisse auf dem Laufen?
Ja, ja.
Wir haben alle Ergebnisse bekommen.
Leider sagen Sie, dass Sie bei uns mehr als 2-3 Tage bleiben.
Wir haben leider...
Wir können jetzt abbrechen.
Jetzt ist unser Gespräch zu Ende.
Wir machen jetzt manöwakritätik.
Danke schön.
Ja, gut.
Hat jemand etwas zu sagen?
Wir können das Üriastest mit Gastroskopie durchführen.
Noch mal bitte.
Üriastest...
Das macht man bei der ÖGD mit.
Genau.
Gut.
Sprachlich haben Sie unheimlich gut angefangen.
Es wurde dann im Laufe der Zeit immer ein bisschen chaotisch.
Man kann sie gut verstehen.
Sie sprechen sehr zügig.
Aber grammatikalisch machen Sie ein Haufen Dreher rein.
Satzstellung stimmt nicht so ganz.
Wenn ich immer unterbrochen hätte, wären wir in 2 Stunden noch nicht fertig.
Ich habe sie durchlaufen lassen.
Es ist ein bisschen schwierig, da ein Punkt zu machen.
Sie fühlen sich sehr sicher in der Sprache.
Aber sie machen noch ziemlich viele kleine Fehler.
Das ist nichts, was die Verständigung einschränkt.
Ich habe nie zwischendurch gefragt, wie sie das meinten.
Es fällt mir auf, dass Satzstellung sehr durcheinander ist.
Eine Sache hat sie hartnäckig ignoriert.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, dass sie seit Wochenbauchschmerzen hat.
Sie haben gesagt, sie hat seit gestern Bauchschmerzen gehabt.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das ist effektiv eine falsche Info gewesen.
Aber ansonsten haben sie ja komplett erzählt.
Sie haben alles, was sie vorher abgefragt haben, gut erzählt.
Augenblick.
Und auch Diagnose und Therapie.
Sie haben auch die Erfindung aufgenommen.
Und eigentlich auch Diagnose und Therapie,
haben sie inhaltlich gut gesagt.
Haben sie aufgeführt.
Da kamen noch ein paar Zusätze von den Kollegen.
kann passieren. Aber eigentlich haben sie schon sehr vollständig berichtet und ein gutes Bild gegeben
und auch eine vernünftige Diagnose gestellt, aber sprachlich war es wie gesagt noch so ein...
Ja, ein bisschen ruhiger Land. Ja, ja, ja, ich berichte. Ich habe viele mal...
Versuchen Sie vielleicht ein bisschen Tempo rauszunehmen. Sie sprechen ja sehr schnell, ich auch.
Ja, ich dachte am Anfang wegen dieser Melena, ich habe festgestellt, ja, das ist die Gastroenterik
des Nagelutungs. Im Laufe der Zeit werde ich ein bisschen durcheinander, würde ich, weil ich habe
festgestellt, dass die Diagnose ist so, aber ich brauche immer mehr Fragen zu organisieren,
deswegen habe ich einen... Und eine Sache ist mir aufgefallen. Am Anfang fand ich das als
Patientin sehr nett, dass sie so mehrfach gesagt haben, ja, ich verstehe sie, ja, ist gut. Aber wenn
sie das nach jeder Frage sagen oder nach jeder Antwort, dann wird es irgendwann ein bisschen
abgenudelt, ja. Also jedes Mal muss man es nicht sagen, aber hin und wieder, ja, wenn was
kompliziert ist, ja, dann kann man das sagen. Danke schön. Also ich glaube, ich glaube nochmal so
ein bisschen sich bewusst machen, wie die Satzreihenfolge ist und... Also gerade für den Bericht, ja,
im Geist ein paar Vorformulierungen fertig haben, ja, dass man, dass man praktisch nur noch das
Ergebnis einsetzen muss, ja, wäre nicht schlecht und ein bisschen mehr Ruhe reinbringen,
ins Sprechen, ja, dass ihnen diese Schnelligkeit, das Fehler nicht unterlaufen, ja. Denn eigentlich sind
sie mit der Sprache ziemlich gut vertraut, ja. Aber wenn es dann so schnell geht, dann holbert
ein bisschen. Also bei den Fragen am Anfang war es ja eigentlich relativ gut und wurde dann im Laufe des
Gesprächs immer kritischer. Danke schön für die alle. Ja, gut, ich hoffe, ich demotiviere sie nicht
zu sehr, aber wir müssen ja auch irgendwo ehrlich bleiben. Wenn ich allen sage, Mensch, ihr seid
klasse, ja, dann wundern Sie sich, wann Sie hinterher in der Prüfung Ärger kriegen, ja. Das ist kein
Mitgenutzt, ja. Insofern, ja. Ja, Gravitikfelder habe ich von einem, meinem Kollegen schon
diese Stofferberichten, aber wegen dieser, ich verstehe sie gut, okay, klar, ja, das war sehr
frei für mich. Also wenn man das hin und wieder macht, ist okay, aber nicht nach jedem Ding,
ja, dann wirkt es so ein bisschen aufgesetzt.